We're about to do a fight scene,
which means I need to give you the disclaimer.
This is Jill Bearup,
extremely qualified actor-combatant,
with years of experience
and a YouTube channel,
where she breaks down fight scenes
and does experiments with swords.
We have had several days of rehearsal.
We have a fight coordinator on set.
We have a lot of people doing
a lot of things to keep us safe.
So please,
do not try this at home.
Woah!
Ack!
Tom and I are shooting
a fight scene,
which culminates in him
getting thrown out the window.
So he's coming into my bar,
and I don't want him there,
because he's barred,
we have a fight about it,
I smash a bottle over his head,
put his hat back on him,
and chuck him through a window.
He's probably feeling terrified.
I would be.
But, he's gonna do great.
A newbie like Tom,
it starts from the first warmup.
I start warming them up,
and I start seeing their mobility,
their general confidence,
their energy levels.
Gaah!
(cackles)
And then I start to think,
are there any moves
that I've planned,
that this will facilitate?
Are there any moves
that we could really show off
this element of physicality?
And with Tom...
I was going into this thinking,
"We're gonna have to be very simple.
"We're gonna have to cut
a lot of the choreography out."
It's gonna have to be very short."
And... within the first
few hours of day one,
he'd pretty much nailed
— not to performance speed —
but nailed the choreography
of the hardest phrase in the fight.
And at that point, I was like,
"We're not gonna have an issue here."
There's a lot to remember,
from a novice's perspective,
'cause I've got to...
not only remember the choreography,
and remember,
eye contact before each thing,
so we know we're both ready.
Yep.
But also to remember performing.
Like, I've gotta just not be...
running through the moves.
I've gotta make sure my face
is doing the right thing as well.
There's a lot to cover.
When you do this on a stage...
Yeah.
You don't get multiple takes.
That's terrifying.
You do not.
But we rehearse it.
We rehearse the scene as much as
we rehearse the choreography.
So you learn the moves,
and you get them into your brain,
and then the next day,
you come in and go,
"Right, what are the lines,
and how do they fit in?"
There are three things,
which people are scared of.
Especially if, like you or me,
when you start, you've never done it before.
You're scared of hurting yourself,
you're scared of hurting other people,
and you're scared of them hurting you.
In choreography, there's usually
one thing which will get you bruises.
Not because you're
hitting each other very hard...
but because you're hitting each other
not very hard, repeatedly.
Yeah, this arm, this arm.
You've gotta wail on this arm
like three times.
And I've gotta remember to react.
That's the thing.
'Cause I'm just there going,
"Ehh, ehh."
And it's like, "Oh, no. I've gotta react
like you're really hitting me there."
Yep.
And I'm gonna forget
to do that at least once.
It's okay.
Like, it's all in the reaction, really.
Yeah.
Because, the reaction is
how you make me look good.
And the reactions are
how I make you look good.
'Kay.
D'oh!
So, aside from things like
victim control...
Yep.
...and contact...
Could've warned me!
...we have a couple of other ways...
of making— (wheezes)
of making real things fake.
First one is distance —
we change the distance,
from what would
actually be a punch in the face,
so that this punch is not going
far enough to hit Jill.
Okay.
So worst case, I can't hit you.
The other one's displacement.
So what we're doing here...
is imagining that there's
a parrot sat on Jill's shoulder,
and Tom's gonna knock it out.
And if the timing of the interaction
matches up,
it should look like
it's just popped her in the nose,
and she's gone backwards.
There we go.
Now if we turn 90 degrees...
Yeah. That's not gonna work.
we see that Tom is actually...
not looking at Jill at all.
He's looking over her shoulder.
I still need to make eye contact,
to cue the things that happen.
To make sure that she's happy to
go ahead with this move.
So in addition to
distance and displacement
— which we use as much as possible,
because they're the safest —
we have victim control,
which is bio-mechanical tricking.
I have this.
I am not holding onto Tom at all.
I'm not doing anything.
There's nothing there.
I'm letting him lead me around,
but making it look like
I'm leading him.
You are the line of safety
for yourself and for me.
I'm hopefully gonna remember
distancing and displacement,
and everything like that.
I'm terrified I'm not going to.
I'm terrified I'm gonna hit you in the face.
I know how far away you are,
and I don't have to
close my eyes at any point.
So, if you get it wrong...
even if that take is scrubbed, like,
you're not gonna hit me in the face.
Okay.
'Cause I know where you are...
...and I will move.
Okay.
If you trust yourself, then you know
where you are in space,
and you know
where your partner is,
and so you know that
you're safe,
because even if
they do something wrong,
you can move.
Whoa, hold it.
You can get closer,
the more you trust each other.
I absolutely trust Tom.
And—
Thank you.
I don't trust me! (laughs)
You're fine, you're fine!
(chuckles)
♪ (upbeat country music)
I feel like
I wanna try something more.
(music ends)
Ohh! (chuckles)
Seeing it on there is—
It's brilliant.
This is fun, Jill!
(giggles)
Told you!
♪ (music restarts)
Thought I told you...
to stay out of my bar!
So I'm kicking...
not getting that high.
I'm kicking 'bout...
Keep kneeling.
Action.
Guh!
Told you, you're not
welcome in my bar!
You moved!
(music ends)
When we're doing a fight scene,
we need to really consider the space.
Like, as a director, I'm making sure
that the framing of it
includes everything in terms of location,
but isn't so tight that
the camera might get hit
when they're actually fighting.
So when we're positioning the camera,
we need to make sure that
we're giving them enough space
to move around
without also sort of pulling punches,
because they think
they might hit the camera.
Weapons are on set now.
We are treating them as though
they are live, sharp, and steel.
Even though they're plastic,
they're still pointy.
And just for good practice,
just for good practice,
we're gonna treat these
like they're live. Okay?
Dodging the knife, right.
Dodging the knife, left.
Get kicked,
move out of the way,
block the stab,
grab the knife, reverse it,
take the knife, hold it...
Ideally, the consequences,
if you don't do the move correctly,
are that you stop it
halfway through.
So if you saw me
forget to kick Tom,
and then... come in
for a stab around,
I stopped before I got to him,
because I realise that
he hadn't actually moved.
We're both aware of
each other's positions.
And if the other person's
not in the right place,
we can't really make the eye contact,
like the cue... manoeuvre...
Yeah.
that tells our opponent,
"We're okay to move."
Yeah. Like, the thing that I like most
about stage combat is basically:
You don't have an opponent.
You have a partner.
And your job is to make them
look as badass as possible.
And hopefully, they are doing
the same thing for you.
Well, you're both looking badass,
so you're obviously both doing your jobs.
One person is.
(clank, rip)
(solid knocks)
Keeping the natural posture
I'm exhausted.
just means that you can come out...
I'm absolutely exhausted.
I've got one more in me,
then we need to break for lunch.
I don't know about Jill.
Yep, that sounds good to me.
Okay.
Nope.
You okay?
Yeah.
All this movement is
victim-controlled, including the jump,
but because the jump
could benefit from, like, an assist,
we're having Tom put
a little bit of lift in there,
as Jill is jumping,
and Tom's just assisting.
What we're doing is
dialing down the amount of assist,
because it's putting Jill
a little bit too off-balance.
Also, my arm's starting to get tired from,
we must've done this fifteen times now.
So I'm starting to lose my grip
a bit there.
The pillar slam is hard,
but I'm controlling the speed.
Jill is just following along there,
and I'm actually pulling her.
She's just doing...
the acting required
to make it look like I'm being pushed,
and we're struggling.
And I just feel for the pillar
with my heel.
And as soon as I hit it...
then the rest of me can go back,
and my head never actually makes contact.
I just have to wince enough
to sell it.
(chuckles nervously)
Hm?
(screams in pain)
Let's see how it looks again.
Ooh, that looks terrifying.
Well, that the thing.
Nice, big surface area.
Oh, I know, but that's a...
I was thinking, beer bottle.
This is— This is big.
But I can see
the seam down it, just there.
So I know that's a fake bottle,
'cause it hasn't been...
Yeah, that's—
The beer bottles are nasty,
'cause sometimes they can have
that ridge in the middle.
Yeah. But I can see
the seam down the side.
If this was an actual...
actual wine bottle,
it wouldn't have that
little bit down there.
Yeah.
Alright.
Cool. Let's do it.
No, just hold it.
Just the weight of it
is surprising.
Oh! That's really light.
Yeah.
And slightly sticky.
So, off this, I'm dazed.
Slammed into the bar.
Jill puts her hand up there.
Go ahead.
I cover it, and...
So if you take your hand away,
I can still go...
And then with the hand there...
So all I have to do is
tense up...
but not my arm.
So I tense up the rest of me,
as if I'm actually doing that,
but what he's doing is drawing himself up,
and putting himself down.
I don't put any pressure on—
You still have to sell it, though.
Yeah. I do.
You still have to sell it.
Alright.
So what I do is...
and I let him...
I let the arm follow him.
(chuckles)
I hit myself. Except I don't.
I keep a little bit of distance.
In the most professional way possible,
I am looking forward to
bottling Tom Scott.
I'm looking forward to being bottled.
(giggles)
As soon as the glass is
about to go: eyes.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay?
Very, very, very delicate.
Alright.
In case you gotta protect them...
Running.
Action.
Gggaaahh!
(faint knock)
Oooh!
Oh, don't— I'm fine.
You should've kept going!
I'm so sorry!
(crew laughs)
I thought I'd actually hit you!
No, I did. I completely misjudged that.
I hit my head hard.
But don't—
Keep the take going!
You alright?
No, I'm fine. Do that again.
Inevitably, we prepare you
that there's always one,
and to not freak out
when it happens, and you didn't!
I thought I'd pushed his head
into the bar,
and possibly given him
a concussion, and so...
(laughs) I guess I...
I heard the noise and I went,
"No, that is the sound of
someone's head hitting wood.
"I need to stop now."
Which to be fair,
is exactly the right thing.
My immediate thing was,
"Oh, why have we stopped?
I just misjudged that. I'm fine."
But yeah,
it was the correct thing to do.
Despite the frustration of,
"Yeah, we can cut to another angle."
Action.
Guh...
Two days' rehearsals, and...
I am now about to
jump through a window.
And... yeah.
Just trying to keep that
out of shot.
It's been a big couple of days.
I'm gonna ache like hell tomorrow,
but it's been brilliant.
Okay, fantastic.
Nice work, guys.
So there's three sheets of
breakaway glass in here,
which are... exceptionally fragile,
because they're designed
to break
the moment that our performer
jumps through them.
Okay.
Yeah, so the whole day has been
building up to this, in theory.
And that is a little terrifying,
because we've never worked with
this breakaway glass stuff before.
This is our first time using it.
It's Tom's first time
doing this stunt for real.
And it's our first time doing it.
We've got Jack here,
to make sure the whole thing is safe.
Obviously, that's
our primary concern.
But the kind of other
secondary concern for us,
after Tom's safety,
is getting the glass
— which is relatively fragile,
we hear —
into this window frame without breaking it
before we've even done the stunt.
So, we're just gonna be
slow and methodical,
and it's gonna be a bit of
a learning experience for all of us.
But yeah, again, the primary concern
for all of us is Tom's safety.
So beyond that, we're just gonna
do what we can to make it look great.
And hopefully, we won't break
all three panes of glass before we do the stunt.
See, I just need to
learn to roll first, so...
It's not learning. It's revisiting.
Yeah, that's a roll. There we go.
This is activating muscle memory
from like 20, 30 years ago.
Just think about getting
the back of that shoulder on the mat.
Okay.
It's all you need to do.
Whoa, not quite.
You're still going over. All you're doing
is kinda skipping your head.
Yeah.
♪ (bass guitar melody)
Oh! That was my head
on the floor.
You alright?
Yeah. (sighs)
♪ (folk music builds)
Okay.
Gah, no.
No, I completely lost that.
Oh no.
Oh, my head.
Look at the boxes.
Nearly.
Ooh! No.
Alright down there?
Yeah.
Full height, tuck in,
look back.
Look back at the box.
Okay.
Looking at the back!
♪ (music ends)
Nailed it.
So, next step is to do it
with eyes shut.
The thing that
keeps me safe right now...
is that I know I have to look
at that, just there.
As long as I go eyes, back of box,
everything else follows.
'Cause I know I have to move my head,
and I have to move—
and everything just follows,
and now I have to get to here...
close my eyes, and imagine
looking at the box.
So, let's see how that goes.
Yes!
Yep, nailed it.
Close enough.
I didn't nail it.
But it's close enough for...
Are you injured?
No, I'm not.
Did you hit the sides?
No, I didn't.
Perfect.
Alright.
Tom is doing so well.
Like, he came in yesterday.
"Ooh, I'm a bit worried.
I'm not very flexible.
"I'm not very physically coordinated."
And now he's diving over boxes
like he's Captain America.
It's really nice to see, because...
when I came in and did my first
stage combat stuff,
I was like, "I don't know if
I'm gonna be any good at this at all."
And so, if it turns out that
you're kind of okay at it,
or you're pretty good
at some things,
and it's fun,
then it's the best feeling in the world.
We're sort of playing it
a little bit fast and loose with the...
the sort of reality of the space,
I suppose.
It's just, we're being a bit
kind of Disneyland,
kind of smoke-and-mirrors
with all of it.
And I think you're gonna
see it so briefly...
that we're not even gonna be worrying
about exactly what we're seeing,
'cause we're gonna be focusing on
Tom Scott jumping through a window.
So, we've got the window frame here.
Yep.
The next thing to shoot is
through the glass.
So we're gonna do it
through the empty pane.
Yep. Few practice rolls.
Get it dialed in.
Yes.
I should be wearing my hat
for this, shouldn't I?
'Cause I'll wear a hat for it.
You've done this many times already.
Tuck, look back.
Look back.
Close my eyes as I go through.
Still pretend to look back.
Alright. Alright.
Ready? Let's do it!
Alright. Yep.
I need to do this once,
and then the glass needs to go in,
and I need to do it again.
Alright. You ready in there?
This is the test. Here we go.
I landed badly,
but I can do that.
Do you want to do one more?
It was a safe landing.
It was a shoulder landing.
I can do that.
Do you want to do one more?
Let's go. No.
Are you sure?
Yes.
We're good. That was it.
That was the shot. That was—
If there was glass in there,
that would've been perfect.
Let's get the glass in.
Let's do it.
Tom, you seem
pretty pumped up right now.
Oh, that's entirely adrenaline.
I'm— I'm running on adrenaline there.
I know I have to do that
through glass in a minute, but...
That's dialed in now.
I know the movement I need to do.
I just need to do that and ignore the fact
that there's glass in the way.
Elbow's gonna go first,
head's going second with the hat on.
I need to close my eyes
and pretend I'm looking back.
And if I nail those three things,
I'm gonna be safe.
If I lose my nerve,
I'm in trouble.
If you lose your nerve, stop.
And walk back to the beginning
and start again.
Okay.
It's very scary to have to throw yourself
through a pane of glass.
It's very scary to have to dive-roll
under any circumstances.
But it's worse to have to do that,
and then wait...
until the very fragile pane of glass
has been taken out,
and put in the frame,
and screwed on,
and then glued and everything else.
And then have to do it again,
knowing that there's something there.
So, like...
I'm so proud.
He's done so well.
We good? Fantastic.
Eyes closed, tuck, look back.
Okay, let's step away.
Right, I'm gonna pace this out.
It's gonna be...
Right, left, right, and through. Okay.
Quiet on set please, everyone!
Alright.
Okay.
Eyes closed, tuck, look back.
Look back, absolutely.
Exactly like you've done it, Tom.
Yep.
Just... a piece of glass in the way.
You're gonna smash it. Quite literally.
I can't actually see the glass there,
which helps a lot.
That is good.
We've got a thumbs-up from there.
Definite thumbs up?
Camera speed.
Sound speed.
Set.
They're set inside there?
I think we're ready.
Someone call action,
otherwise I'm not gonna do it.
And... action!
Coffee.
Decaf.
Whoa! Gah!
I told you to stay out of my bar!
You've moved!
Apparently, not far enough!
(clank, rip)
(solid knocks)
(chuckles nervously)
Where are you getting those?
Pockets.
No knives?
No knives.
♪ (percussive music)
Hm?
(screams in pain)
Cut!
Yes!
(crew cheer)
(applause)
Here we go.
(laughter and applause)
Amazing work, Tom.
I mean, so the thing is,
you can't see my face in that shot,
so it looks like a stunt op,
but we've got so many cameras on that.
Yeah, we're good.
[Caption+ by JS*
https://caption.plus]